my name is Gerry Hargrove let's see
where am I I'm a cloud architect and
evangelist at a company called
lucidchart and my role there is to go
out and I do a lot of research and
experimentation and talking about cloud
technologies and specifically AWS my
background as you can see my twitter
handle is AWS geek so I've been working
in AWS as an employee at AWS as a
developer as the Solutions Architect as
a customer of AWS and as a partner of
AWS so I have a background in AWS and
lucidchart
pays me to go out and talk about cloud
technologies and where our lucidchart
shirts so if anybody is on Twitter and
you take a picture of this today mention
me so that they know I'm actually out
doing my job traveling around the
country so today I'm gonna talk about
building a machine learn learning enable
bots on AWS and this is based on some
experimentation and projects that I
worked on earlier this year and I'm
gonna share with you sort of my
experience with that and my journey
through sort of learning about machine
learning on AWS this isn't going to be a
tutorial really on machine learning how
many of you here work in data analytics
or machine learning already
so yeah I'm you guys you'll roll your
eyes today at some of the things I'll
probably say about machine learning
you're y'all are probably the experts in
this space I come at it from an AWS
perspective from a practical application
so I'm gonna I'm not going to talk in
depth about machine learning I'm gonna
talk about building this so let me ask
you a question how many of you know what
aircraft that is I just thought when
landing out here this morning at Dulles
what a380 so how did you know that was
an a380 double decker okay what else
what are the other cues
it's huge yeah it's I mean it's it's big
that is a that's an a380 landing in
Munich but yeah you can see
double-decker it's got four engines so
two on each side yeah it's it's huge
even you know the carrier Emirates they
have a bunch of a380s so it's easy for
us to see and and pick out visual cues
and identifiers that tell us what type
of aircraft this is but if you know the
absence of AI and machine learning how
would you how would you write an
application or a code to do this I mean
you know if you think back you know 10
years ago and not even not even thinking
about a problem that's complex we would
probably build some sort of rules based
system right we do a lot of ifs and then
Xand else's and and I still can't
imagine how I would build a system to do
this and so I set off earlier this year
I part of my role as travelling and so I
get to see I get to sit in a lot of
airports I get to see a lot of aircraft
and this seemed like a good way for me
to explore machine learning on AWS and
in particular sort of visualization of
data and so I built this this is a
Twitter bot that's on Twitter right now
it's called aircraft ml if you go to
aircraft ml on Twitter and you tweet an
image of an aircraft to it it will tell
you what type of aircraft that is so
it's it's mainly been trained on modern
commercial aircraft like a380s and and
737s if you if you send it a picture of
an old or a military aircraft it won't
be able to tell you what it is but so
this talk today is really based on it's
a tutorial around building a system that
is similar to this now if you built this
itself this is what it would look like
on AWS how many of you are AWS users so
that's it that's a good good chunk of
you half of you are familiar at least
use AWS so that system that I just
showed is is this right here
and I won't spend a whole lot of time
talking about it but just to go through
some of the major parts so how that
system works on on Twitter is someone
tweets to aircraft ml and gives it a
picture that tweet is actually sent to
number two here API gateway on AWS we'll
talk a little bit more about that so
it's an HTTP endpoint sort of the public
interface to AWS that in turn invokes a
lambda function a serverless function
number three that takes that request
from Twitter parses the JSON puts that
request into a and SQS queue number four
that act triggers another lambda
function which takes that request out of
the queue number five and then that's
where it actually starts working on the
image so it takes that image uses number
six
another lambda function that these
lambda functions all have machine
learning models that they use to process
images with this one here actually looks
at the image and says is there an
aircraft in this image at all or are
there multiple if there are then it
takes that image it crops it maybe there
are multiples of them and sends each one
of those to number seven the actual
aircraft classifier itself which says
okay that looks like a 737 that looks
like an a380 and then I also use number
8 and 11 to do sort of tail number
detection so detecting text in an image
using regular expressions to determine
whether it looked like a tail number and
then looking that tail number in a
database online so that that's that was
all aircraft ml I'm we're not going to
build this today we don't have that much
time I was talking earlier about how
long it actually took me to build that
initial application sort of as a side
project probably took three or four
months just playing around with it
experimenting with it and learning the
services now we could build it in just a
couple of hours but it does take some
time to just learn about the services
and figure out what they can do and
stitch it all together so what this
tutorial today is going to do is focus
really on sort of
main path through here and that is the
sort of the end point which is Twitter
we're going to use slack instead we're
going to use number two API gateway and
some lambda functions and ultimately
we're gonna build this right here we
have just enough time for me to walk
through this and build this we're gonna
use slack as the public interface we're
gonna use API gateway as a public HTTP
interface into an AWS system a couple of
lambda functions to actually execute
code and then we're gonna use Amazon
sage maker as the machine learning
backend for this system and s3 as well
to store the model so here's how we're
gonna do it real quickly I've broken
this up into four labs I'll tell you a
little bit more about these in just a
few minutes first one is going to be
setting up sage maker anybody here use
sage maker before all right so we've got
a couple people who have used it I'll
talk about it second lab is building
sort of this private interface will set
up a lambda function then that allows us
to execute or exercise the machine
learning model created with sage maker
third we'll set up a public interface
using API gateway in another lambda
function and finally we will create a
slack bot that you can actually go into
a slack workspace and call out a bot and
say hey tell me what kind of aircraft
this is so before we get started that
you'll get the most out of this if you
have some experience on AWS I'm not
going to go into great detail about
Amazon Web Services and the particular
services that I'm going to there we'll
talk about today I'll mention them
high-level what they're used for but
you'll want to go off and dig into them
some more to get the most out of this
also like I mentioned most of you or
many of you have more experience with AI
and machine learning than I do I
approach this from a beginner's
perspective with relatively none and so
I'm I may say some things that again
you'll probably roll your eyes and think
you know he really doesn't know what
he's talking about that's true when it
comes to machine learning in AI
definitely not so you
the most out of this if you have some
experience with AI and machine learning
on your own if you want to follow along
everything that I'm going to be doing
today so looking at the bottom there is
in a github repo this is a tutorial that
I've built I'm actually going to use it
to go through this today if you have an
AWS account and you want to go through
this with me today as we go along you're
more than welcome to do that
you'll also need a slack workspace
ultimately that only takes a few seconds
to set up if you're online if if you do
want to play around with this send me an
email at this email address Gerry at AWS
geek comm and I'll send you an AWS
credit code which will you can apply it
to your AWS account and I believe it's
it's either 50 or $100 worth of AWS
credits which is a nice chunk to play
around with for building this system
here today just in the 90 minutes that
we have it probably we probably maybe 10
and dollars or less of AWS resources
assuming you spin them up and spin them
back down when we're done so make sure
you do that all right so let's go ahead
and and get started so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to walk through this and
I'll stop in between each one of these
labs to if there see if there are any
questions to see where we're at and see
if there's anything else you'd like to
know well we'll do the first two and
then we'll take maybe a five minute
break and do some more questions and
then we'll finish finish up with the
last two so lab 1 this first section is
building the actual classifier itself
and so that's using Amazon sage maker
and s3 so for those of you who haven't
used sage maker before so sage maker is
gives you the ability to build machine
learning models to train them and then
to deploy them and to do so at scale so
as if you were going to build a
production system that you wanted to use
these machine learning models in so it
will actually orchestrate training of
machine learning models it will
facilitate building endpoints and
deploying machine learning model
so that you can use them execute them
through HTTP endpoints and it will
manage scaling that out so you can build
elastic systems that will scale to your
needs under the hood it's it's really
just a it provides you with a Jupiter
notebook and a shell around you know
machine learning frameworks like MX net
or tensor flow or other ones that are
out there so it really for someone like
me who doesn't know a whole lot about
those underlying frameworks it really
just it provides you with access to the
knobs and the buttons that allows you to
experiment with them without having to
get into all the gory details of
starting up an ec2 instance installing
one of these frameworks configuring it
running it yourself
so if you were to build a machine
learning model out at scale and you
wanted to build a cluster of GPU
instances to actually train your model
Sage maker will help do that for you
instead of you having to do that
yourself so for someone like me who is
new to machine learning this is a great
way or great introduction to it so for
this model that we're going to build
today so what we're going to build is a
machine learning model that will take as
input an image that includes an aircraft
in it and as output provide you with the
type of aircraft and specifically today
these labels aren't correct here but
we're going to build a model that will
identify one of three aircraft a 747 a
a320 and and one other aircraft and so
we're going to use sage maker to build
this model that takes those inputs
trains a model and then allows us then
to perform some prediction on it once
that model is created so we're gonna put
in an unlabeled image that it hasn't
seen before and hopefully it outputs a
the right type of aircraft how many of
you have built machine learning systems
like this so more object detection image
classification image processing okay so
we've got a couple how about others who
have built machine learning systems
around you know data analysis so yeah I
was at a Google conference not too long
ago
they mentioned that 95% of their machine
learning work at Google it's not this
this is sort of for me this is sort of
the sexy part of machine learning where
I can use images and visualize it but
95% of what they do is actually just
processing that data you know click data
ecommerce data etc so with that I'm
going to jump into this so I'm using
this github repo that I mentioned
everything that I'm going to talk about
is here I'm going to walk through this
tutorial just like you might and so you
can see how easy it is to do this I'm
gonna build this inside of inside of an
hour and a half and let me know I saw
someone stand up now that's it a hundred
and fifty percent so we'll we'll leave
it there so I'm gonna use these these
tutorials I'm going to walk through it
the couple prerequisites again if you
have it you're gonna need an AWS account
if you want to follow along and a slack
account one thing to to make note of
here is that for this tutorial when you
do this make sure that you create all of
your AWS resources in the same region
and make sure that all of the services
that we're going to use are in that
region the only one that you have might
have to question is sage maker whether
it's available in all AWS regions and an
API gateway for that matter but for the
most part they're all available I'm
gonna I'm going to use a single region I
think Ohio to do this today just because
I don't have any AWS resources there and
it'll be easy for me to clean up
afterward so I'm just going to jump into
this and and we'll get started
so to train an aircraft classifier this
is lab 1 the first thing we need is an
s3 bucket in an s3 bucket we'll use that
to store the actual resulting model
that's built and we'll use it to store
the inputs to this system so we're going
to go to s3 and make sure that's the
right size yep and I'm going to create a
bucket I'm gonna call it here I've
already got one already
AWS geek ml classify and I
the region here is us East Ohio again
I'm going to put all of my resources
there so I'm going to create a bucket in
u.s. East Ohio actually I'm going to
copy that name because I'm gonna need it
in just a second and I'm just gonna
click on create that's all you have to
do now we have an object store in Ohio
that we can use to store these objects
that that's that's the only setup we
need here now we're actually going to go
and create a sage maker notebook
everybody familiar with Jupiter
notebooks or many of you are so really
that's the first thing we're going to do
is we're gonna spin up a sage maker
notebook instance and that's what we're
going to use to ultimately to to train
this model so I've got some convenient
links here that you can use when you're
doing this open the link make sure that
we're in the same region as our s3
bucket and we're going to create a
notebook instance now for today's
purposes I'm going to call everything ml
classify and there if you follow along
in here the only thing we're going to
use all of the defaults except for here
I am role we're gonna create a new role
so identity and access management allows
you to dictate what permissions this
lambda or this what permissions sage
maker has and just in general other
services within AWS and specifically
tier today for sage maker what we're
creating an eye I am role that allows
sage maker to access our s3 bucket and
that's exactly what this is doing and
why I copied that s3 bucket name this is
going to create an iam role that gives
sage maker permission to read and write
from that bucket that I just created
that's all it does so I'm going to
create that role and then go back to the
sage maker console here everything else
can remain default we're not going to
use a VP see no lifecycle configuration
the volume size here is sufficient five
gigabytes
really we just need to be worried about
how much data we're gonna be pulling
down into the notebook and what its
gonna be processing locally and this is
sufficient so we'll create a notebook
instance here whoops that is because I
didn't clean up last night all right so
I'm gonna create ML classify chew and
I'm gonna use the same execution rule
here so I'm just gonna create that and
this will take just a minute so back
behind the scenes what what's happening
is AWS is actually spinning up a
notebook instance for us and like if you
were spinning up an ec2 instance this
might take a minute for for that to
happen so we're just gonna sit here and
think about this so the next steps after
this once we've got this notebook
instance up we're going to go download
the actual notebook that I have created
and then we're going to execute some of
the code in this notebook and we'll walk
through each of the steps this is
probably the longest portion of this is
actually creating this the notebook and
then training the model as you'll see as
we get further along into this the model
that I'm creating i've provided all the
sample images for us and we're only
going to do a couple of epics on it so
that it doesn't take too long to
actually train it obviously if we were
in a production environment then this
would take longer and we'd spend a lot
more time on it but we only have an hour
and a half to do this today so we'll
take what we can get and this should
just take a minute here of course it
always takes longer when you're staring
at it
there we go
go get in there nope not yet so one of
the things we'll come back to this a
little bit later so this provides sage
maker provides us sort of this view into
this machine learning environment and
we'll come back to this in a few minutes
but we'll come back we'll be able to see
when we kick off training we'll be able
to look at the logs associated with
training as though we were looking at
the logs on an ec2 instances that was
running this training so we'll come back
to this console a little bit later on
once this once this kicks off and we can
actually start using it so now it's in
service and I'll go back to the actual
tutorial here so that we're following
along we've created the I am role again
all of these steps were following these
exactly we're going to load a we're
gonna click on open to open the the
Jupiter notebook and then I've created a
a notebook here we're gonna copy the
link to that this is hosted on an s3 in
an s3 bucket and we're gonna load that
into our Jupiter notebook so if we go
back to let me make sure this is zoomed
there we go a little bit bigger
hopefully everybody can see that I'm
just gonna upload that file there and
it's gonna download it from s3 and then
upload and it tries to rename it here so
I just clean that up
and now we have this notebook that's
ready for us and we click on it we can
go into it and start executing some of
the code so most of the code that you're
going to see to the GAE is Python I'm
assuming everybody here is familiar with
Python so we won't talk a whole lot
about it but once we once we get into
this we're gonna start training our
model once we get the the notebook up
and running here so a couple of things
I'm going to do here
since we're actually going to be doing
training I'm gonna start executing these
and then we'll come back and talk to
them but so we have these cells inside
of this notebook that we're going to be
executing I think there are four of them
altogether one thing we have to do is we
need to specify the eight the s3 bucket
that we're using and so this is a WS key
kml classify just to make sure where is
it there it is right there so here's
that bucket nothing in it right now so
I'm going to change that name here
that's really the only change that you
have to make to this notebook and then
I'm going to execute it and then we'll
talk about it so I'm gonna run it and
then we'll see we'll know that it's
running it's going to output some text
but really all this first cell is doing
is it's copying these training files
down from my s3 bucket so there are two
files there so I've already gone out and
collected about 1,500 images of these
three different types of aircraft and
I've packaged them up and separated them
out there are two files 95% of the
images are in the training file and the
other 5% are in the validation file so
when ml classified or when sage maker
builds the model it's going to train
with the training images and then we'll
use the validation images question so no
they are no I so I didn't do any
pre-processing on them now there there
are aircraft turns out to be a pretty
easy model to build because there are
aviation enthusiast sites out on the web
where they have done all the hard work
of taking the pictures and labeling them
and categorizing them and make sure then
making sure that they're high enough
quality and so I didn't do a lot of that
work other than just scraping some
images off of some websites here but
there there's a little bit of
pre-processing and you'll see when the
model is set up and I'll talk about I'll
talk about that
what is your data structure like yeah
this is somebody else may know this file
format a little bit better it's it's a
wreck file format where they take all of
the images you could and compress them
all into a single file so it's it's I
don't think it's anything really super
special other than a convenient way for
this particular model or algorithm to
access those images so this that's
actually done now we can see they've
copied these two files down cell 2 is is
weird grab your question in just a
second I'll start this so I'm actually
gonna run this because this I'm glossing
over a lot here again this is the
machine learning part of it so we're
actually going to train the model now
this is gonna take about eight minutes
that's why I started it and kicked it
off but you had a question back in the
corner so well I can tell you the
framework so you can access frameworks
like MX net tensor flow glue on there
there a whole bunch of common libraries
and they change them or they're updating
them all the time and so frameworks and
there are some other libraries you have
to look at Sage Maker specifically to
see what's there so but you can you can
install whatever you'd like and then
what what what usually ends up happening
is if you really want to get deep and
into the weeds with these frameworks you
then you go back to just doing it on an
ec2 instance so sage maker provides sort
of an abstraction not really an
abstraction but it hides a lot of the
details so what's happening here and
I'll we'll talk a little bit about this
so I've kicked off this training session
and it's using one of the image
classification samples that comes with
sage maker so if we go back here to the
sage maker console or the Jupiter
notebook console there are a bunch of
sage maker examples that come with it
and these are notebooks that you can use
an experiment with I'm actually this is
based on one of these image
classification
samples that comes with sage maker and
specifically we're gonna this ones doing
transfer learning on a existing model
and and using and then providing
aircraft images so we can get some
specific classification for that but
looking at what's actually happening in
this cell of of code that we just
executed its setting up a training job
its configuring some of the hyper
parameters associated with creating this
model a couple of interesting ones we're
using 50 layers you can use 18 I think
3450 and there's a hundred a couple of
couple that are over a hundred number of
training samples 1425 so that's 475 each
for each of the different types of
aircraft and then there are 25 each for
validation there are three different
classes so it's going to attempt to
class classify these into three
different chunks here's where so I'm
doing some things here to specifically
make this training session so short so
that it finishes in seven minutes and
I'm like for example I'm only using five
epics and that that's definitely not
enough to to get really accurate when
we're all done here
I think validation accuracy of this
model is going to be about 85 or 87
percent which is not very high when I
built the system that you saw earlier
aircraft ml on Twitter instead of 500
images each I had 10,000 images each and
it ran for I think 30 or 50 iterations
and that ended up taking that even then
using a cluster of three or four p38
extra-large instances with GPUs it only
took a couple of hours to do that so I'm
doing a lot of things here to shorten
that up and also using a pre trained
model so we're using trick we're good
we're going to do transfer learning in
this case which means sage maker is
going to use an existing model that's
been trained to detect and classify
general objects and then we're going to
be building this model on top of that so
it's just peeling the top couple of
layers off of that model and then train
training our system our three aircraft
on top of that so that makes it a lot
quicker without that we couldn't even
get to 85 in five iterations we'd
probably be down at about 20% here so
augmentation type here this we are doing
a little bit of processing on these
images so this this adds some
randomization to the actual input images
so it's it's cropping each image a
little bit different from the next one
it's doing some a little bit of
transformation so it might it might
rotate it a few degrees one way or the
other one of the downsides of using
images from these aviation enthusiast
sites as training material for this
model is they're all from the exact same
angle so they're all profile images of
aircraft and so this model is very good
at classifying aircraft that you see a
profile of but if you were to go to an
airport and take a picture of an
aircraft at a gate sort of from an
oblique angle it's not very good at that
and so this tries to do a little bit of
that so let's look and see where we're
at
so we can still see this is in progress
so let's go into sage maker itself and
see what's going on so we can look at
the training jobs we can see one here is
in progress you can see the other ones
that I've done they'll run around seven
minutes so we can look at this
particular job that we created and
what's running
input parameters here then you can see
the the hyper parameters here that we
just talked about there are other ones
here that you can change I just happen
to use these what I really want to get
down here to is the monitoring section
and logs so now we can go in and look at
the logs associated with this training
job and you'll see here right now let's
see if I can expand that a little bit
but you can get some idea let's scroll
down here you can see it's on
EPIK one it validation accuracy was 87%
and this should roll along pretty
quickly now actually that seems like
it's moving a little bit slow this
morning so usually what happens this
ends up taking about seven seven or
eight minutes to this and it gets around
eighty-eight percent accuracy so we
should be getting 33 40
so we're actually getting we're getting
closer so we're up at about 92% so again
this will this will get us sort of in
the ballpark and it's enough for the
simple examples that I'm going to be
doing this morning yeah question if so
it could be that you may have to request
it so if it's using a p2 extra large
they may have a limitation on the number
of GPU enabled instances that you can
create or which region did you try it in
Ohio
you could try you could try it with a
different instance type a non GPU
instance of course that's gonna make it
slower but that that would be my only
recommendation it or some you might have
to submit a support case to AWS and ask
them to increase your limit on p2 or p3
instances
so we should be getting closer here yeah
so validation accuracy we're actually at
about 92% here which is a little better
than normal if I go back to if I go back
to the console here actually if I go
back to the console and look at training
jobs we should be getting close to
completed yes it was completed so that
that model is now done it's it's just
gone through five iterations again real
quick example of how you can use this
more more time you'll spend more time
actually configuring it and setting it
up and learning it and then you know
kicking off the training the training
job once we go back here now we see that
the training job is actually complete
the next step is deploying the model so
I'm going to kick that off before and
this again will take a few minutes so
what's happening now is this model is
being deployed so AWS Sage Maker is
taking that model that we created and we
can go back to our s3 bucket now and
look at what's in it we see now there's
here are the two files that we copied
down when we executed the first cell of
the jupiter notebook there's also an ml
classified directory if we look in that
directory and go down a couple of levels
we'll see this model that we just
created right there so that's the model
that it's going to use so now what it's
doing is it's creating an endpoint a
publicly accessible endpoint that you
can use or your customers can use to
actually exercise this model and it's
doing so here so it's creating this it
has the the endpoint name and the
endpoint arn we're going to use both of
those in the in the next couple of steps
so to test the model this again is going
to take about five minutes because under
the hood
sage maker is actually spinning up an
instance and deploying this model and
setting it up for us
while we're waiting for this to finish
we can get started I'm going to jump
ahead and and skip into the next section
and we'll come back to this so we'll
skip into lab number two which is
setting up the setting up the private
interface so right now we're creating
the the stage maker model and we're
deploying it now we're gonna create a
lambda function that wraps it so we can
actually call it from other functions
easily through lambda so before I roll
into that any questions on the first
part we're going to come back to it and
test it well it's once the end point is
done any questions up to this point
about sage maker I can answer you know
to the extent I can any comments all
right so we'll go into the second
section here and this this is where we
start actually writing code and using
code to execute this model so we're
going to create a private interface and
we're gonna build a lambda function to
do that how many of you have used lambda
on AWS what language is Python node
Python anybody use other than Python
okay so we're gonna do the same thing
we're gonna create a lambda function
today that execute Python code if you
haven't used lambda before this is AWS
as serverless offering so you write the
code AWS handles it manages it executes
it for you
you don't have to deal with operating
systems you don't pay for ec2 instances
that are running 24 by 7 if your
function is only executed once a day for
10 seconds that's all you pay for you
pay for that 10 seconds that it's
executing there's a cost associated with
the amount of memory that you need and
the CPU that you use but that's it so it
can be a very efficient way to to
execute code on AWS as a matter of fact
aircraft ml which I built you saw I
didn't use sage maker in aircraft ml if
you look at the the the architecture
here there's no sage maker in it
that's because this is a hobby site if
you run sage maker you're paying for
sage maker endpoints and instances 24/7
and my wife looks at this bill every
month and wonders why I'm paying for
people to classify aircraft I can't
justify sage maker for a month but I can
justify lambda and so for the couple of
times a week when someone wants to
classify an aircraft this executes it
costs a couple of pennies I keep my wife
happy you have a question for me it was
all about cost it really was at some
point I didn't look to see where the
intersection was where it made more
sense but at some point it will make
sense to potentially switch over to two
sage maker really sage maker is a
managed you know the sage maker endpoint
is a managed service that manages
effectively ec2 instances for you that
are running these models or perhaps
containers probably more likely that
they're running in min containers but
then there's a little bit of a premium
for that there's a premium for lambda2
so III didn't calculate it but at some
point there is an intersection of those
two lines where it would make more sense
to do that so it's probably you know not
a great answer but it's gonna it's going
to vary for everybody who does it
I also one other reason that I chose
lambda for this was I received some
credits from AWS that didn't include
sage maker so I got free money from AWS
that I could use but it didn't cover
sage maker so any of the training that I
did on sage maker had to come out of my
own pocket so ultimately I ended up
doing all of this on ec2 and in lambda
all right so let's create a lambda
function actually I'll go back and check
and see if this is dunyah and see if we
can test it yet nope not done so let's
get started over here we're going to
create a lambda function so we're going
to go and we're going to create a lambda
function called ml classify we're going
to go to the console here lambda console
and author from scratch we're gonna call
it ml classify Python three six it could
probably be two seven but for now we'll
use three six four I am for roll we're
going to create a custom roll and again
we're creating an identity and access
management role for this lambda function
that only gives it permission to execute
that sage maker endpoint so here we're
going to select create a new iam role
and all of these instructions
step-by-step are in on github so if you
want to follow along there we're gonna
create a new role I'm gonna name it
whoops ml classify just to be consistent
so that when I come back and I want to
clean up all of this after we're done I
can do that very easily click on allow
and then it's going to take you back
here to the lambda creation page now
it's switch to choose an existing role
and ml classify the one that I just
created and create the function now that
gave that creation we didn't actually
give it permission to do anything we
just created a role that it's going to
use now we need to go back in and update
that iam role and we're going to give it
permission to execute that sage maker
endpoint so this really all it does is
give the lambda function permission to
call the sage maker invoke endpoint
method so if we go back to the ml
classify role that we just created and I
click on add in line policy and then on
the JSON tab you can do this a couple of
ways whoops
I'm gonna edit this and let's see if I
can expand that so you can see what I
just did
so I just pasted it in this JSON that's
an I am role again all it gives this
function the ability to do is invoke a
sage maker endpoint but we do need to
have the sage maker endpoint arn you
could give it ability to execute any
sage maker endpoint arn you could just
put in this and it get in it could
execute any but we want to be real
specific around it about this so I'm
going to go back here and in this output
from our Jupiter notebook we see the
sage maker endpoint iron right there so
I'm going to copy that
and then I'm going to go back to the I
am role and I'm going to give it just
permission to execute this one in sage
maker endpoint or invoke this one
endpoint review policy I'm going to give
it a name ml classify and I'm going to
create it alright so now we have this IM
role that gives it only permission to
invoke a sage maker endpoint and as a
lambda function it also needs permission
to write to logs and so these are the
only permissions this function have so
you don't have to worry about you know
it's probably more of an issue if you
were doing this on an ec2 instance of
someone compromising the instance and
taking advantage of your AWS system one
thing I noticed when I was back here I
noticed that this endpoint has finished
its creation and so now we have this
endpoint in sage maker out there that is
available for testing so let's go ahead
and test it through the Jupiter notebook
just so we can see that it's actually
working
so this first cell right here all it
does is download an image from an s3
bucket of mine and it will display it
for us so we can see that we're actually
working with a real image that's an a320
in Munich and now in the next cell we're
actually going to take that image and
we're going to hand it off to sage maker
and have it process that image and then
give us back the result and then we'll
print out what that result is so I'm
just gonna run this right now and
hopefully this works yes so it's taken
that image it's classified it as an
Airbus a320 with very high probability
well sort of high probability but of the
three that was the highest probability
so that so getting to that point was
very simple it's it's a very crude model
in terms of its ability to really
accurately identify aircraft but it does
the job and it demonstrates what you can
do with it this code that he is here
this Python code is almost exactly the
same code that we're altima League owing
to put into that lambda function that I
just created so this is really the end
of the sage maker portion of this lab
we've created a model we've deployed it
now it's ready for us to use and so
we're going to go back to two lambda and
build our lambda function to now execute
that so any questions about sage maker
before I move on that that's that
they'll probably be the last time I talk
about it but you can always ask
questions later on or catch me after
this so if we go back to lab number two
now where we're starting to build the
lambda function now now we need to go
and actually update the lambda function
to call that sage maker endpoint if you
look at the existing lambda function now
that we just created this is it just
some boilerplate code it doesn't do
anything you can execute it it's not
gonna do anything for you so I already
have some code here that you can take
and copy paste into that function and
use directly the only change that you'll
need to make is right here on line 17
we need the endpoint name so it's not
the sage maker endpoint iron
it's the sage maker endpoint name which
we can go back here to our Jupiter
notebook and we see it right here
endpoint name so we're just going to
grab this name
go back to the lambda function and let
me squeeze this down a little bit and
we're going to replace this with that
name and click on save so if we look at
this code really all it's doing is it's
a lambda function it's look at the the
event that's passed to the lambda
function is now going to contain a URL
parameter that correspond that points to
an image of an aircraft and then we're
going to once this updates we're gonna
extract the bytes from yeah
perfect timing Who am I Who am i today
there we go so if we look at this
function not now we look at this
function really all it's doing is all
right we're gonna do that again
that didn't take step back copy paste
and then I need to grab the end point
name again so I'm just redoing the last
couple of steps because it was in the
process of logging me out while I was
doing that
all right so lambda function updated the
endpoint name and save it really all
this lambda function is doing as I
mentioned is is grabbing a URL and
downloading the bytes associated with
that URL I want to mention here that
this is not production code I'm not
doing any checks or validation of the
URLs or the data that's contained in
them this code is just for this example
so you can see clearly what's going on
I'm just getting the URL downloading the
the actual bytes associated with that
image so I'm not checking to see whether
it's an image or not and then I'm
passing those bytes on to sage maker in
this function here or in this call here
to do classification on so it you can
see very clearly what it's doing then
then I'm parsing the scores
I'm actually going to change this
because I'm going to set it to you so
what it's going to do then is look and
see if the result comes back and it's
higher than 85% then it's gonna say yes
this is an aircraft and here is the
here's the type of aircraft it's gonna
do a lookup of of these names up here so
I'm gonna save this function and if we
go back to the lab now we're gonna
create a test for it so we're gonna do
effectively the same thing we did in
sage maker but now through lamda so I'm
going to create a test event that
contains a kind of a URL that we can use
to test the lambda function so if we go
up here to the lambda function we do the
select a test event drop down and
configure test events I'm going to
create an event I'm just going to paste
in that actually I'm going to do the
Airbus a320 because I know that works
a320 we just don't want to seven and
we'll call it ml classify and then I'm
going to save it or create it so now now
what happens is if I click on the test
button it's going to use that event that
we just created here and it's going to
execute this lambda function and that
event is going to contain that JSON that
I just paste it in here so crossing my
fingers that this all works right I
click test it calls that sage maker
endpoint and it does return hey that's
an Airbus a320 so this tests the the
lambda function the lambda function is
calling the where we ant here the lambda
function is calling the sage maker
endpoint and the sage maker endpoint is
actually looking at that image
processing it and determining what kind
of aircraft is in it
so that is that we've really gotten to
the end of the second part of this which
is creating this private interface using
you know we've used Sage Maker we've
used lamda and we've used s3 to this
point it's you know the actual AWS
infrastructure that we're using is
pretty simple and straightforward at
least from my perspective I've used a
lot of AWS it may be a little more
difficult than that but you're probably
saying the same thing about machine
learning the machine learning I've kind
of glossed over but you can see that if
if you're not a machine learning expert
or even if you are you can pretty easily
use sage maker to build these models and
like I used images because that's easy
for me to understand it easy for me to
see and and you know realize the
benefits of machine learning fairly
quickly for you it might be some other
data type you can use sage maker for
more than just images you can use it for
any type of machine learning model
creation so before I go to the second
half we take like just five minutes if
you have questions or comments or you
want to know more detail happy to happy
to answer any questions you have right
now go ahead
I wondered what the artist
so the the the training jobs themselves
are one of the interesting things is if
you go to the sage maker console of
course everything is timed out now I'll
have to refresh all of these pages
the training jobs themselves so the the
job itself the configuration is just a
configuration file when you actually
train your model this is happening on a
separate training instance so when when
we created a if you look at maybe I
didn't talk about this directly when we
created the training job here one of the
part of the configuration you had hyper
parameters I also specified resources to
be used for this training job and what
it did was it spun up a single P to
extra-large instance and this is where
the training actually occurs in my case
I only wanted one instance to be used
and I specified a volume size of 50 so I
don't know if that does that answer your
question this is where the training
actually occurs on those instances and
it's interesting to note that these
instances are spun up you do your
training on them and then AWS terminates
those instances so you're not paying for
them while they're while training is not
actually happening the notebook instance
on the other hand you're responsible for
starting and stopping it so that you're
not paying for it while it's not being
used and the same for the end point if
you're not using an end point you can
stop it
you just have to say to make their
notebook open and running allocating
those resources no so the the the the
the the Neptune so right now I've
deployed an endpoint that's hosting that
model so that's that's that's an AWS
resource that I'm paying for and as long
as it's up and running I have to
explicitly go in now and tear it down
and I can call it from this Jupiter
model from this notebook I'm sorry that
the Jupiter notebook or I can call it
from a lambda function or I could call
it from any other code you know I could
use the AWS one of the AWS SDKs for
example running on on-premises systems
and call this code two
so the end point so the notebook is is a
an interface into building this and
executing code associated with building
the model the end point itself is a
separate AWS resource that's been
deployed that actually now hosts that
model so you can that I like to think of
using the notebook the jupiter notebook
for actually building and configuring
and testing creating the model itself
the endpoint is all about hosting and
deploying it under the hood it's
probably an ec2 instance that's my guess
I don't know the details of it any other
any other questions or comments
were you able to get beyond that did its
did you try changing anything that's
that's my guess is that there's probably
a resource limit depending on your
account if you haven't used sage maker
before they may have a limit on the
number of GPU instances there are other
sage maker instance types you can go
into sage maker where we add on time how
much time do we have left
ok I'm gonna roll through this you can
go into sage maker and you can select
non GPU instance types so I'll go ahead
and get started on the second half of
this which is actually a little bit
quicker because we're not dealing with
machine learning so we're going to go in
to lab 3 now and we're going to create a
public interface so we're going to
create another lambda function that
really acts as a public interface so
it's going to accept requests from slack
and then hand them off to ml classify so
we're going to create another lambda
function and let's see here
create another lambda function we're
going to do almost exactly actually it
is the exact same steps as we did before
I'm going to call it ml bot named it
Python or it's going to use Python 3 6
we're going to create a custom role go
through the same steps as before yes
again create a new role because we want
to give it explicit permissions we're
gonna call it ml bot just for
consistency's sake and then go back and
create this create this function and
then we're going to go in and modify the
IAM role associated with that with that
lambda function and we'll go right here
go directly to that iam role we're gonna
do the same thing as we did before we're
gonna add an inline policy go to JSON
itself and just paste this in you're
gonna see that we need the ml classify
function R now so this lambda function
is simply going to call another lambda
function so we're going to chain these
together so we only want to give it
permissions to do exactly that
so I'm going to go to the ml classify
function and I'm just going to grab the
a RN associated with it so this is just
an amazon resource identifier associated
with this particular lambda function
you'll see it for other resources too
like s3 or SNS topics for example so
we're going to grab that let's go back
to I am and paste this in and now by
creating this policy and associating it
with that lambda function we are now
giving it permission to execute just
that other lambda function and that's it
no more no less
now we've created this now we have this
this lambda function it has permission
to execute another lambda function let's
go back and change the code in this
lambda function and I'll talk about this
code in just a second it'll make sense
in just a minute whoops
I can't copy and paste
all right so all again all of this code
is available on github you can copy and
paste it very easily lambda function ml
bot that we just created boilerplate
code I'm gonna paste this in all this
code does is so for the next step we're
going to create a slack bot slack wants
to verify an end point all this code
does right now is return a correct
response to that validation call and you
can see here it looks for it parses the
event it looks for a particular event
type and then it returns a particular
value and then slack this is all slack
wants to say yes this is a good end
point I can send I can send subsequent
information to it so we're gonna save
that now I want to create an API gateway
and there so an API gateway is going to
provide an external endpoint for slack
to call when it wants to send messages
to our bot and we're going to use API
gateway for that there are a couple of
ways of creating an API gateway one is
to go through the API gateway console
configure it create the endpoint specify
you want it to respond to get or post or
you know what the end URL is a much
easier way of doing that is actually
configuring a trigger on the lambda
function so they've made it super easy
to do this in lambda if you go into your
lambda function ml bot and you go in the
designer section under add triggers and
select API gateway and then scroll down
this will do all of that for you so this
is going to create an API gateway for us
it's going to configure it and then it's
going to give us the URL that we're
going to need to provide to slack so
under API if I use just create a new API
and then specify security is open what
this means is anybody can call that HTTP
endpoint you could also make it more
restrictive by providing an API key say
you hand out an API key to your
customers who you want to use this
endpoint or you can use identity and
access management for us we're just
going to leave it open so anybody can
call that
and then create or click on add this
cues that change up once you actually
save this function it will take care of
creating that API gave gateway endpoint
for us and then it will show down here
there it is right now that is the
interface into our system we're going to
come back to this because I'm gonna need
it in just a second we're gonna provide
that URL to to slack so now that we've
created the API gateway let's go to the
sort of the last part of this section
we're going to come back here and update
that lambda function in just a minute
but for the time being we want to go
ahead and create a slack workspace and a
slack bot so if if you have slack if you
have slack at your work you may not have
permissions to do this I found it's much
easier just to create your own slack
workspace it only create it only takes a
few minutes to do it and then create
your own bot so that's what I'm going to
do here I'm going to create an app and
it will update here in just a second
hopefully
I'm on
there we go okay so we're gonna create a
slack app all these URLs are in that
document so real easy to do this you
create an app but I'm going to call it
ml bot I'm going to choose a workspace
that I use last week so I'm going to
create this new bot in this workspace or
I'm going to create this new app in this
workspace so again this is super easy to
do on slack it would take you a little
bit longer to do it on Twitter
I chose slack just because it's so much
easier and then once you've created the
app you're actually gonna create an ml
bot user so there are a couple of ways
to interact with slack and some of you
may be used or familiar with slack
commands you can do you can do slack
commands to interact with AWS or you can
use a bot user I found using a bot user
is just much easier because it expects
all interaction to be asynchronous with
slack commands you actually have to
respond right away when you get a
request and then you can do some
asynchronous processing after that this
is just much easier to do using a bot
user so we're going to create a bot user
in slack call it ml bot use the defaults
will show it always is online just so
it's easy to find click on add a bot
user so now we have a bot application
and we have a bot user next step is to
install the app so we have these we have
this app and we have this user but no
one on our slack workspace can see it
until we actually install it so we just
go under settings go to install and
click on install app to workspace
they've made this super easy to build
these for slack so it's it's real easy
to build BOTS and slack now and then we
authorize it for our our workspace and
you'll see that it gives us some tokens
back we're gonna come back and grab
these in a couple minutes because when
we respond to slack from our lambda
function it wants one of these tokens so
it knows who it's talking about but
we'll come back to that the next thing
we're gonna do is create an event
subscription now on slack what we want
to have happen if someone mentions ml
bot says hey Emma bot here's an image
tell me what it is we want that to be
sent to our
our lambda function and so in slack what
the way to do that is to create an event
subscription and with an event
subscription we can specify what events
we're listening for and slack will send
those events to our endpoint so first we
want to enable events and now it wants
this request you our URL here's where
you're going to send here's where slack
is going to send these events that's
where our API gateway endpoint comes
into play so if we go back to our lambda
function and we copy this API gateway
endpoint address as soon as we paste it
into this box slack is going to send
that validation call through our API
gateway into our lambda function and
we'll see that it's validating it and
hopefully we get a green checkmark here
saying that it's working so you'll see
as soon as I pasted it verifying
verified so now now you can see this
indicates that it made that call through
API gateway API gateway called our
lambda function lambda function parsed
that request and returned the correct
response that that's really it
so pretty straightforward at this point
we've actually created an event
subscription we've subscribed we're
going we're going to go back here and
now subscribe to a bot event as I
mentioned we want to subscribe to a
Pynchon so anytime someone says @ ml bot
image will get that will get that
request through our API gateway and
lambda function so I'm going to save
those changes at this point I mean that
was super easy that's all it takes to
create a simple bot on slack you saw me
do it five minutes and you have a system
that can now that you can use for
testing and interacting with not just
machine learning systems on the backend
but any AWS infrastructure or endpoint
the next step is to go in and update the
lambda function that we created right
now that lambda function does nothing
but respond to slack and says yes I am
who you think I am we need to update
this
so that it actually calls our lambda
function and then returns a response to
slack so luckily all that code is right
here it's not very much and it does
exactly what you think it would do so
let's copy this into our lambda function
back here and then we'll walk through it
and we can see what it does it needs a
couple of things it needs the ml
classify function arm here it is I
already have it highlighted so the
lambda function needs here it has to
know who it's going to be what function
it's going to be calling so I paste that
in there and remember that token I
mentioned earlier from slack we need
that here so anytime we send a response
back to slack it's going to contain that
token so we can go back to slack and go
to OAuth and permissions and we'll find
that token right right here bought user
OAuth access token so if you just click
on this button here it will copy it we
go back to our lambda function and paste
it in right there and save it did i nope
yeah that's gonna break isn't it thank
you
that one right is that it got it thank
you so I'll walk through this real real
quickly again standard lambda function
everything is passed in through an event
right now this event is going to be the
JSON data that slack passes it we're
going to grab the appropriate data out
so if it says another URL verification
that code is still there so it still
responds correctly but we're really
looking for this event callback event
type we're going to extract the text out
of that event so you can look slack has
documented that the event one of the
fields is text which contains the execs
associated with whatever message was
sent to ml Bob and then we're just I'm
doing a simple comparison I expect it in
a particular format and I'll show you
what that is but this this reg regular
expression is going to be used I really
look for here's a command and then
there's going to be a URL so again not
production code this works in this very
specific use case but it demonstrates
how you could do this so I have a
regular expression it pulls out the
command and then ultimately we're going
to use it to look up the lambda function
that we're going to call so here I
extract the text I do the regular
expression search on it and if I get a
match then I pull out the command and I
pull out the URL and then I take that
though that information and then I call
the ML classify function so I send it
the URL and it in turn calls sage maker
model the sage maker endpoint does
classification on it we're gonna get the
results back here and then we're going
to configure and send a message back to
slack so there's an endpoint a slack URL
that we're going to send this to and
we're going to send this information
along with the text that's returned by
the the other lambda function so super
simple super easy to do the really the
only thing so we've got at this point
we've finished that we've actually added
the slack bot that the only the only
thing left to do is actually to send a
message to to our system from slack and
so if I go back here I've got a couple
of canned messages first let's try one
that we know should work so here's this
Airbus a320 aircraft that we've tested
before if I go to slack now let's create
a new channel in oops let's create a new
channel and now ml bot I've installed it
so we're gonna invite ml bot to this
channel so we'll start listening for
requests if you don't do that you won't
get a response now if I go into into
slack and type in a message like this so
you can see the format here's dimension
@ ml bot here's the command classify we
could have made this much simpler I did
it this way because I wanted if you look
at the lambda function I want to be able
to do different things so I can send
this way I can do different commands so
I just have to modify this regular
expression and update this function
lookup and it will let let me do
different things so now I'm telling it
classify and here's the image so this
works
we should see the image yay so it's
displaying that and we've already got a
response back so this means that it's
communicating through API gateway and
lambda and yay ml bot says it's an
Airbus a320 so this now demonstrates
sort of the end-to-end functionality so
we're taking slack we're sending a
message to ml bot that's going through
API gateway API gateway is handing this
off to a lambda function lambda function
is calling another lambda function
that's invoking a sage maker endpoint so
pretty straightforward let's we haven't
tested it against so this doesn't always
work we if you build this over and over
you'll get different results each time
there's some random aspect to it and so
sometimes you get better models
sometimes you get worse models because
one of the things that we're doing at
least in my case is I'm I'm having sage
maker I mentioned this apply some
rotation and apply some transforms to it
so the images are always going to be a
little bit different in my case so I
always get slightly different results
and so it's a little bit of a crapshoot
whether this is going to work in front
of a bunch of people but that makes it
fun right then I can talk about
different things if it doesn't so let's
go back I've got another let's see a
Boeing 747 let's see what it says there
oh I spelled it wrong so it's not going
to do that right
and you see if it if it just silently
fails there's no you you saw the code
that I wrote it doesn't do any error
checking if it doesn't get if it doesn't
download the the image correctly you'd
have to look in the logs and you see it
probably blew up when it tried to
extract the bytes from a non-existent
image so that one should work so we see
there's a 747 landing in Seattle let's
see what it calls it Boeing 747 I have
one other yeah yeah I just I just
extract the good point good point this
does nothing there's there's actually
nothing behind this but a function that
pulls the string out turn it it's always
someone smarter than me in the audience
how many of you know what a Dornier 328
is again string parsing you're right
oops
okay so it worked half the time I do
this it it doesn't I get incorrect
results but that's because number one
it's it's a small model it's a fault
it's a small training sample we've
trained it the the images that I'm
actually using are pretty small - I
think they're 320 by 240 so they're
they're fairly small and so sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't
on my larger model that I built with
aircraft ml it has a pretty high
accuracy rate on it this one like you
saw a 80% validation rate so that as far
as the tutorial goes you can walk
through all of these steps if you want
to build this yourself go to this repo
and you can extract all of this
information out of there one thing to
make sure though and I'm going to go
through some of this right now is there
are a couple of things that are still
running in AWS right now so if we walked
away you would still have some resources
that are costing you
one is that sage maker endpoints so ages
AWS has spun up resources that are able
to respond to those requests and you're
paying for those 24/7 it may be a small
amount but ultimately it adds up and if
you have a partner or a spouse and this
is a hobby project they will eventually
notice it and let you know that that's a
true story
then so that's running and and you'll
want to take that down also that Jupiter
notebook there's a notebook instance
that's running that will incur cost over
time I don't know if I don't know if I
called it out or you notice but this
sage maker instance I think was like a
t2 is it I could teach you micro
instance size so cost is pretty minimal
but again those those costs do add up
and so you'll want to go in and the
fifth lab in here is actually about
cleaning up whoops I guess I could just
do this go in and clean up these
resources so sage maker is there the
lambda functions themselves again you're
Pete you pay for lambda on-demand when
it's executing so while they're sitting
idle there's really no cost associated
with them API gateway resources I don't
I don't have to go look and see what
cost is associated with those sitting
idle but if you're not using it you'd
might as well tear it down otherwise
there's a public-facing endpoint that's
just sitting out there not doing
anything
I am resources again not doing anything
but I like to go in and clean them all
up when I'm done that's why I named them
all the same s3 you've got an s3 bucket
out there now that holds this model
there is going to be some ongoing cost
associated with that
so again if you spin this up play around
with it for a couple hours and then tear
it all down it's probably only a couple
of dollars on AWS let's see so to kind
of wind down tear it down clean up again
if if you want to try this out send me
an email you don't necessarily have to
include your AWS account number but send
me an email by the end of the conference
and I'll respond with an AWS credit that
you know I believe there 50 or $100 but
in any case it's me it's way more than
enough to play around with this all of
the guides all of the code that I just
walked through fairly quickly are
available in this github repo so try
them out and give me any feedback and
with that if you if you want to see more
you can follow me on AWS geek see some
stuff on AWS geek comm I do these
hand-drawn diagrams on my iPad for AWS
services that are kind of interesting
and I write on the little lucid chart
blog so with that I'd like to thank
everybody for coming today I appreciate
you coming out this early in the morning
it's like 6 o'clock for me it's 9
o'clock for you but that's okay I
appreciate it and take any questions
that you have now we've got about what
we have 10 minutes about 10 minutes or
so so
you have any more questions you want to
dive deep on anything go ahead yeah so
all I'll update these and I'll put them
out in the github repository to probably
just a PDF of the slides great great
question so I didn't include that here
but all of everything I did today I did
through the console through the AWS
console you can do all of this the model
creation is probably a little iffy but
all of the other infrastructure the
lambda functions API gateways endpoints
so you can do it in a couple of steps
but you could do most of this in cloud
formation so you still have to train the
model offline and then just tell cloud
formation or yeah specifying cloud
formation that sage maker endpoint
should use this model so and then you'd
have to do the slack integration of
course but all of this could be
completely automated couple manual steps
so you may build a system like this and
then periodically update the model for
example very easily
other questions yeah go ahead
yeah there's you could actually do this
in a couple of ways I went down that
path because if if we go back to go back
to here it sort of behaves similar to
this and so I was using this as a model
where there's a a single lambda function
that essentially handles all the
requests and then dispatches them and so
this sort of mimic that you had a public
you sort of have this public lambda
function that parsed the input and then
dispatched the the request to the
appropriate handler so you could you
could actually combine both of those
together there's there's no real
compelling reason to separate them
although it made a nice breaking point
or a you know point in the in the
tutorial to talk about different things
but yeah there's there's no real in this
particular application no real
compelling reason to do that
any other questions all right that's it
thank you all for coming appreciate it
[Applause]